bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24 soy herminia fernández
comenzamos
el 2 de abril de 2022 se cumplieron 40
años del inicio de la guerra de las
malvinas como se le llama en argentina
el conflicto enfrentó al país
sudamericano con reino unido tras una
ofensiva lanzada por el entonces
gobierno militar argentino y fue
motivado por una disputa de soberanía
que todavía no ha cesado el
enfrentamiento dejó 649 combatientes
argentinos y 255 británicos muertos y
una herida profunda en la sociedad
argentina además de deudas pendientes
especialmente para quienes fueron
protagonistas de esta guerra nos
acompaña nuestro corresponsal en
argentina natal yo soy autor de este
reporteros natalio en el reportaje que
veremos a continuación entrevistó a
varios ex combatientes argentinos de las
malvinas
oakland island como le llaman los
ingleses puedes contarnos cuál es la
situación actual de estos ex soldados
después de 40 años del conflicto
bueno ellos tienen un largo recorrido
primero cuando volví a las clases
superiores les decían que se prepararan
que la gente no los iba a recibir bien
tras la derrota y los sorprendió la
buena recepción de la gente que además
les ofrecía comida y lo vivaba pero
pasaron mucho tiempo si se quiere en una
suerte de olvido reclamando atención por
parte de argentina especialmente del
estado pidiendo pensiones ayudas
económicas y sobre todo una fundamental
cobertura de salud que es un tema clave
para los excombatientes especialmente el
de la salud mental después de la guerra
ya de regreso en argentina las
asociaciones de ex combatientes estiman
que más de 300 ex soldados se quitaron
la vida por la presión de lo que
llevaban encima tras la guerra ese es un
tema clave para ellos también el de los
abusos que sufrieron en las islas por
parte de sus superiores que recordemos
formaban parte de una dictadura militar
en argentina y trasladaron algunas de
las prácticas que tenían aquí allí a las
islas de hecho y juicios por esos abusos
y lo que creo que en el reportero lo que
vamos a ver claramente es cuán presentes
están malvinas en el día a día todos los
excombatientes por los combates por los
abusos que mencionaba por el frío y por
el hambre que pasaron en las islas si
natalio también queremos saber cuál es
el estatus actual del reclamo de
argentina sobre las islas pasaron 40
años de la guerra y pareciera que se
está en la misma situación que hace
cuatro décadas atrás
si argentina nunca ha dejado de reclamar
la soberanía de las islas tiene que
programadas por los británicos en 1833
antes de la guerra de 1982 había algunos
acercamientos diplomáticos más sólidos
que podrían tal vez haber llevado algún
tipo de solución de compromiso eso se
terminó con la guerra argentina insiste
todo el tiempo con argumentos históricos
y argumentos geográficos para defender
la soberanía de los históricos son que
antes de 1833 había habitantes
argentinos en las islas que fueron
desplazados por los británicos y el
geográfico tiene que ver con que las
islas según argentina forman parte de la
plataforma continental de este país
además argentina argumenta que la
situación actual de las islas es un
resabio de color de colonialismo y el
reino unido responde sosteniendo que se
trata de una situación de
autodeterminación del pueblo de las
islas que decidió por un referendo en el
año 2013 que quería seguir como un
territorio de ultramar británico algo
que desestima argentina que considera
que los habitantes de las islas no están
en esa posición por ser una población
implantada así que argentina sigue
insistiendo en todos los foros posibles
internacional que reino unido se siente
a negociar como dispuso la resolución
2065 de naciones unidas- del año 1965 en
el marco de los procesos de
descolonización
eso sí argentino insiste que quiere
hacerlo de forma pacífica sí gracias
natal yo aquí la historia
[Música]
germán mona ni vive con su esposa
adriana eran novios en el secundario se
separaron tras la guerra de malvinas y
se reencontraron muchos años después y
hoy pues te alabamos yo vive con él
mismo el vídeo esa cuesta el bajo del
autor y lo primero que me dijo fue sabes
que volví a malvinas yo siempre digo
malvinas nos unió nos separó y nos
volvió a mí en su casa germán tiene una
pared llena de recuerdos de esa guerra
que le cambió la vida son objetos de
valor sentimental que mantiene desde que
hizo su primer viaje a las islas luego
del conflicto este me guarda y tiene
25 años de intemperie
todavía recuerda los últimos días en el
atlántico sur esa noche del 13 de junio
cuando junto con sus compañeros debió
correr 8 kilómetros para ponerse a
resguardo en medio de los bombardeos
en ese momento donde la cuenta pero s
y
por qué cayó ahí yo podía haber ido dos
metros más para allá o el tipo del
mortero podía haber tirado cinco
céntimos acá es eso
no es fácil para por lo menos para mí
frecuentemente germán se reencuentra con
sus compañeros de guerra en el pse sin
el centro de ex combatientes islas
malvinas de la plata a pesar de lo duro
que vivieron en el centro de
excombatientes no falta el humor
el 2 de abril el señor el indi me
informa que habíamos recuperado malvinas
y yo le dije yo gordon le digo estás
borracho
y me acosté a dormir porque a las 6
llega a las 5 de la mañana a las 6
teníamos formación entonces
así que él fue el que me informó que
habíamos recuperado madriles
me digo tengo un suficiente
tomamos las islas malvinas
no sé dónde quedan así que le digo no
allá donde el pasto era las compañías
con variadas veces esta plaza está llena
de recuerdos para marcelo hoy es un
lugar conmemorativo de la guerra pero en
1982 era el regimiento desde donde
muchos conscriptos partieron hacia el
conflicto algunos resultaron heridos en
malvinas a otros las secuelas les
aparecieron en forma repentina 20 años
después de la guerra marcelo miraba en
la televisión una película sobre el
conflicto y tuvo un ataque que lo afectó
gravemente y mi señora dice que estuve
toda la noche tragando
me voy a dormir y al otro día
ya no me dio antes quede así
si se rueda no caminaba
marcelo se recuperó es uno de los que
sobrevivió la guerra y la posguerra la
borda es de aquella época otros no
soportaron el peso de haber pasado por
malvinas se estima que más de 300
soldados se quitaron la vida al volver
de las islas además de los 649 hombres
que cayeron en combate por ejemplo ayuda
yo la conocí en el número 22 que está
ahí
de 27 que está acá
conocer bien conocido no somos los
héroes están acá esto es un
como el mario gustavo rodríguez uno de
los soldados muertos en la guerra
adriana rodríguez es la hermana de mario
gustavo está visitando museo en el sur
del gran buenos aires- uno de cientos de
espacios que recuerdan la guerra de
malvinas en argentina
esperarlo
era esperar los soñar lo que soñar que
me decían en tal lado está
y esperarlos en el año 2000 adriana
viajo a malvinas a recorrer el
cementerio en el que se suponía que
estaba su hermano y él había llevado esa
platita
que dice gustavo ni el tiempo ni la
distancia
lograrán que te olvidemos con cariño tu
hermana cuñado y sobrinos
mi primera impresión de llegar allá
yo lo primero que dije
cuando íbamos a cementerio porque está
todo desolado
y de la bronca dije por esto por esto se
moría mi hermano
para saber quiénes eran los soldados
argentinos que yacen en las 121 tumbas
del cementerio de darwin en malvinas fue
clave el rol del equipo argentino de
antropología forense
esta es la sala de resguardo de las
muestras de sangre de familiares de los
diferentes proyectos
acá están las muestras de el proyecto el
plan de proyecto humanitario malvinas
nosotros aquí lo que guardamos es toda
la documentación el proyecto humanitario
que comenzó a mediados de 2017 consistió
en tomar muestras de los cuerpos que se
encontraban en el cementerio señalados
con la frase soldado argentino sólo
conocido por dios para intentar
identificarlos contrastando los con
muestras de sus familiares en el proceso
identificaron a mari ha gustado
gustavo me ha gustado la fotito tiene el
corazón que le hizo de llenando las
fotos
la muestra fue de ella de la madre y de
medios hermanos o sea es eso es un caso
que teníamos una muy buena
representación familiar que es lo que no
busca la identificación del cuerpo de su
hermano marcó un hito para adriana yo
pensé que había hecho el duelo pero
cuando encontré su nombre en su tumba y
ahí empezó mi duelo en el año 2010
es loco deje de soñar con mi hermano
no soñé más es como que fue una
confirmación
no fue una confirmación de que no estaba
prisionero
que ahora era libre
y no soñé más con él
como la mayoría de los familiares de los
soldados argentinos enterrados en
malvinas adriana decidió dejar en las
islas el cuerpo de su hermano para mí es
importante que porque que haya
porque esa tierra es es argentina
y si nosotros traemos su cuerpo acá es
cómo darle lugar a
a que esa tierra
inglesa
a 40 años de la guerra tanto los isleños
como reino unido siguen rechazando el
reclamo argentino de soberanía pero el
estado no cede en su reclamo el museo'
malvinas en la ciudad de buenos aires-
es justamente un espacio para la defensa
de la posición argentina sobre la
soberanía de las islas y este es el mapa
bicontinental que fue actualizado
y uno ve en los mapas
tiene mucho de proyección no así porque
uno cuando ve la cordillera de los andes
tiene como que las islas malvinas es una
proyección que sigue por las iglesias
sándwich va por las islas orcadas y
después continúa con la península
antártica así que como que si fuese una
proyección para edgardo esteban la de
malvinas es también una historia
personal fue el primer ex combatiente
que regresó a las islas en 1999
yo fui prisionero de guerra el 14 de
junio en este depósito
y yo dormí mi primer noche como
prisionero de guerra acá
y como ves es y pf yacimientos
petrolíferos fiscales y la empresa
petrolera estatal que tiene la república
argentina
y estaban las islas malvinas era la que
suministraba el combustible si de eso
fue lo contradictorio que había una
proximidad y había un acercamiento muy
grande esa referencia no es casual antes
de la guerra argentina del reino unido
habían avanzado en potenciales
soluciones diplomáticas para el
conflicto sobre la soberanía de las
islas pero el gobierno militar decidió
lanzar la ofensiva que cerró las puertas
que la diplomacia había abierto el mismo
gobierno militar que había aterrorizado
a la población argentina desde su
llegada al poder en 1976 el museo se
encuentra en el terreno donde funciona
la escuela de mecánica de la armada que
fue el mayor centro clandestino de
detención de la dictadura y tiene su
foco puesto también en recordar que la
guerra de malvinas tuvo lugar en ese
contexto
junto de compañeros el vínculo entre la
dictadura y la guerra la continuidad de
los abusos es algo que se hicieron en
cambio propia los soldados conscriptos
que fueron a las islas existen causas en
la justicia por esos abusos pero la
falta de avance en tribunales llevó a
que se reunieron a protestar frente a la
corte suprema- días antes del 40
aniversario del inicio de la guerra
piden que el máximo tribunal determine
que las torturas que sufrieron los
conscriptos son delitos de lesa
humanidad lo más grave y no voy a cansar
de decirlo es el maltrato psicológico
el escuchar judío de [__] o cualquier
adjetivo que puedas imaginar todos los
días de la estadía el hacerme comer
entre el excremento por haber acusarme
de avería o robar comida cosa que no es
cierto
congelar me los miembros del cuerpo en
el agua por mucho tiempo lo cual hizo
que volviera con problemas de
circulación a uno y me duran ese
estaqueado semidesnudo y hacerme orinar
por mis propios compañeros extrañaba a
mi familia tenía 19 años no tenía
contención creo que fueron los días más
difíciles que me tocaron vivir
para que en la historia de malvinas no
se olvide lo que sufrieron los
excombatientes germán ofrece charlas
sobre la guerra en varias instituciones
en representación de su centro de
excombatientes
como en este comedor comunitario en la
periferia de la plata donde lo escuchan
con especial atención
y había que
recuperar así claro porque era de
nuestro territorio pero para germán es
importante recalcar que la realidad de
la guerra está muy alejada de la épica
entonces de repente tenía un casco o sin
armas un cañón
iba
a un lugar puso el pago a recuperarlo a
formar parte de la historia
es decir a partir de la historia de 77
es este como parte de una aventura
empieza el hambre empieza el frío
desgraciadamente los piensos tenían que
cuidar no nos cuidaban y en vez de
ayudarnos nos comportaban la vida
gracias chicos
[Aplausos]
malvinas tiñe todo en la vida de germán
o algo que le ocurre también a sus
compañeros que se reúnen en el centro de
excombatientes de la plata un lugar de
contención en el que los encuentros
siempre terminan con una cena en la que
se comparten anécdotas se ríe y sobre
todo se come y se bebe sin restricciones
para olvidar el hambre que pasaron en
malvinas y mantener vivo el recuerdo de
una guerra llena de contradicciones
hasta aquí reporteros en la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]